today I want to talk to you about the
three different levels of relationship
we create with people our pants remain
to be a host of value tainment and I
want you to think about this year for a
moment everybody you have in your life
personal and business every single
person you have in your life personal
life and business life every one of them
went through three different levels in
our lives where they became who they are
today it could be people you have in
your life that you have a very strong
relationship in business and it could be
people in your life that are very very
strong friends in your business there
was a time they were at level one in
your life I'll explain you what it is
and if you were to look at it like a
filtering system right a filtering
system goes like this there's more at
the first level less like a second level
very few at the last level and here's
what the three levels are the first
level of building relationship is
initiating new contacts in business if
you don't do number one very very well
the chances of you succeeding as an
entrepreneur salesperson or businessman
businesswoman goes lower because you are
not giving yourself enough opportunities
with new relationships that lead into
something bigger so number one is
initiating many many new contact some of
your friends who are your best friends
today in the world at one point you
initiated a new contact could've been at
school could have been at work a
commander Jim it could be yet somewhere
else right second level is maintaining
that relationship so you have initiated
new contact you meet 100 200 300 people
boom a few then become business partners
with you a few then become friends with
you and you maintain that relationship
and some people are very good at
initiating new contact but they're bad
at maintaining relationship some people
are very good at maintaining
relationships but they're very good at
initiating new context you got to kind
of figure out which of these two you're
good at maintaining a relationship could
be if I have a vendor and if I buy
$50,000 worth of equipment from this guy
every three months we've been doing
business together for eight years I buy
he brings delivers on time products are
good they're not broken they're not
messed up we have a very good
relationship together no problem I have
a vendor I work with a publishing firm I
work with an insurance company I work
with a financial firm
I work with they have a certain thing
expectations good we're good to go or
maintain a relationship it could be a
friendship you have a friend you go have
a drink with them you watch a game with
them you have a beer with them you have
coffee with them you go to dinner with
them you double-date with them you go to
gym together you go to a game together
it's a relationship you maintain not
good not bad but it's a good
relationship you're maintaining and
that's kind of where you are with this
person right the highest level of
relationship is advancing relationships
okay so we have creating new contact you
need many of them initiating new contact
you have many of them then you have
maintaining them but the great ones in
life are very good at advancing
relationships let me explain what I mean
by advancing relationships there is a
challenge with going from maintaining
where they sent you to advancing
relationships I'll explain to what I
mean by that so when you have a lot of
different business relationships that
you're maintaining what will happen is
you'll talk to this person you build a
relationship and you'll realize that
person doesn't think that big you'll
talk to this other person come we're
about the same level you know that
person's making 100 you're making 100 by
at the same level you guys got a good
relationship together but that person's
very comfortable at 100 you got a
personal life relationship you got a
girl you got a you know boyfriend or
something like that in your
relationships very good I'm maintaining
but that person kind of pulls you down
sometimes and you want to grow you can't
because it's they just want to maintain
and you want to go and we hear this
whole advanced thing and it's difficult
for a lot of people I'll explain to you
why because life is filled with so many
contradictions so many contradictions
it's insane one contradiction is we've
been told let's go help the entire world
right we hear these but no family left
behind let's go help everybody out great
cause we'll love it a lot of truth and
Noble of value behind what that message
is let's go help everybody up but then
we see these pictures everywhere on
social media on Facebook and books you
read on movies you watch where it's kind
of like you be the outlaws you be the
guy that's the rebel you know the
pictures you see with a hundred robots
standing on one of them is red he stands
that everybody else stays together
the commercial 1984 Apple you know where
it shows the Grove running with the red
she throws the hammer and it's a message
to IBM and it's about being different
being this but then Apple gets hated so
in order for a person to go from
maintaining relationship to advanced
I've experienced it's very very
difficult for a lot of people to do
sometimes going from maintaining
relationship to advancing relationships
you actually minimize your relationships
and you have to choose between I'm
either going to settle and conform and
play a small life to please all of these
friendships that I have or I'm going to
do something bigger and run with a group
of people because I want to advance my
relationship to find a group of people I
can go with long term because we have a
similar vision we have gone through
friction together there's been talks
where it's been feisty but there's a
level of expect acceptance level of
respect level of love level of
camaraderie level of a certain United
group who are filled with honor and
courage and desire to do something
that's been never done before that's
that relationship very few people get
here because they don't like hurting
other people's feelings
they don't like having other people talk
behind their backs they don't like other
people saying things like that
urge you you know all you care about is
money all you care about is if people
have all the time with that but if you
ever want to do anything big in your
life I would rather have a handful of
great friends in my life that I want to
be friends with till the day I die who
accept me for my weaknesses my flaws my
advice my good stuff my bad stuff all of
it the way I am I'd rather have that but
at the same time we challenge each other
to improve not challenge each other to
change the way we are or the way we talk
or now challenge each other to improve I
would rather want bad then somebody who
wants me to change constant because
you're not accepting me who I am I want
to find your running mate I want to find
someone I can run with I want to find
friends that we can come together and do
something special with your lives and
something tells me you do as well I
think you do and if you can find out
these three different levels initiating
new contact maintaining relationship and
advancing relationship and identify
where your weak
sis figure out a way how to improve that
area you'll be blown away by the kind of
results you'll get in your life and by
the way thanks for watching this message
today we had our new book 25 lots we're
doing the impossible that I wrote three
years ago it sold nearly 150 some
thousand copies new language Romanian
translation by impossibile ooh in
Romanian pretty wild on out strands out
in five different languages simplified
Chinese polish Romanian Russian and
English is what we got it on but if you
haven't read it yet click on the link on
the bottom go read the book twenty-five
laws for doing the impossible and post a
review on Amazon what do you like it or
not it's fine I'd love to hear your
reviews about the book and if you got
any thoughts about three different
levels of relationship you got any
questions post your questions on the
bottom we'd love to get back to you have
a great week everybody take care thanks
for watching this video